this could be wrong so hopefully someone
in the comments can like shed some light
on this but oh i could do it too
hopefully someone in the comments when i
went to go study abroad in spain and
talk about things like sex uh in america
like third base is like oral right like
home base is like sex right i believe
over there places in europe it's like
sex is more casual so it's like third
base but like to like get oral sex
that's more like whoa but that's maybe
either more intimate first base is
magnitude orgies
first base is orgies it goes from
physical to emotional i see the first
step is you meet each other in europe
and then you have a 69 yeah and then the
second step is you invite a 69 base one
it's it's when you connect this human
centipede 69. at the end of it decide if
you want to be in a relationship or not
oh i thought it was gonna be you join a
sex cold or not
oh i thought home run was like you hold
hands finally yeah yeah
what are you just avoiding hands the
whole time you're like [ __ ] you're
just like no no no no elbows only if
you're [ __ ] you can suck my dick hold
hands don't touch my hands